how can this guy and this guy come from
the same damn Studio the recent episode
of the mandalorians surprise viewers
with a live-action bfx rendering of Zeb
from the animated Star Wars Rebels that
looks really good I analyzed modox VFX
and I pointed out how wow critics
compared it to George Lopez and Sharkboy
and Lava Girl in 3D modoc's appearance
really improves later in the movie when
his crown is broken so that his face
doesn't look as boxed in and whenever
his head is turned to the side with more
texturing Zeb meanwhile benefits from
less screen time and backlighting the
camera only stays on him for a few
seconds at a time in a scene that lasts
only about a minute and in that time the
artist did some impressive texturing
like notice how as Zeb talks you can see
the wrinkles in his nose and the muscles
around his Temple twitching these
artists really accomplished what the
artists who worked on Avengers Infinity
war did with Thanos they crafted a skull
with additional layers of facial muscles
and ligaments under semi-translucent
skin that they textured with wrinkles
and hairs to make all of it look
lifelike and interact really well with
the light of the room
oh
[Music]